Is it bad to be using my cell phone while using the right machine?
Well, I'd say yes and no.
I mean, I don't think it's interfering with the right machine,
but I do think I don't think that it's necessarily a good thing.
So you're using your cell phone.
You got data flying into your cell phone.
That's with a very strong signal.
I already mentioned before that, I don't think it's a great idea to be using your cell phone right before you go to bed.
Because you're trading your brain at 60 hertz.
More than that, you're putting your causing a lot of EMFs to traverse your system.
And that is not necessarily good either.
You can't ignore the damage of EMFs.
And it does to our body just because we can't see that measure it very well.
So I would say probably not a great idea to use your cell phone while you're doing the right machine.
It's about having balance, of course.
But most of us have our cell phone glued to our handout and we just have to be aware of that.
It's okay to use the right machine while also doing cast oil packs.
Yes, yes, for sure it is.
A matter of fact, I think it might even be better to be running the right volume with cast oil packs.
Because you're stimulating the cancer cells at the same time you're doing cast oil.
That's absorbing it and how we pull toxins out of your liver.
I think there could be a good degree of frequency interchange that could be helpful.
That can be good.